[Music]
in uber 8it news submitted by good night
JK a study says that 28% of delivery
drivers have eaten some of your food one
eight percent that's a lot is 100% of it
french fries sometimes I'm just maybe
like eight percent is like those Taco
Bell likes cinnamon twist things I love
cinema do you resist one if you were
driving them or probably not no I would
eat it I would because you smell it in
the car oh my gosh
now imagine that torture could you
imagine now like if you have the bad
food and that like stinks up your car
though
oh that sucks so a study conducted by us
foods they found a lot of interesting
statistics from delivery people as well
as people who order from delivery apps
how would they know I just what do you
know how would be like like is it a
survey or like how would it conduct a
study I just said it was a survey so
they point them it's a questionnaire
though do any of you guys how did the
study go no I'm hey when while they got
some results process like me what I know
is that they surveyed not 497 drivers
from apps such as uber eats GrubHub door
- and postmates does that answer your
question yeah I guess so do you think
that being honest
I can't believe there were that honest I
it's way more it says at the top the
average person has to food delivery apps
and uses them three times per month
54% start with a restaurant in mind then
look for it in the apps do you guys do
that I spend way too much [ __ ] time
doing that or are you use one I only use
post mates and I use it maybe two or
three times a week
hmm what two to three times a week you
do not you use it way more than that no
I got these guys I got like these meal
prep things oh oh but you used to go
like I still way more you eat maybe two
three times a day yeah yeah
and then a 46% of people starts by
opening an app and then looking for
ideas on what to order so which one do
you guys fall under the 54% of knowing
which restaurant or the 46% of looking
for ideas me I like to look at the
options meet you 46 I enjoy that so it
turns out that the most popular app is
ubereats and the second third is door -
and fourth this post mate oh I'm
in-between GrubHub and post mates
there's also caviar caviar oh I've no
idea it's the only one that does Joan's
on third which is like right by me oh
yeah like literally I could walk to it
but I don't have cold like shitty food
and they're like Google which plays that
I don't know yes it's good
do you guys order a lot of finger foods
no what's a finger food like chicken
strides mozzarella stick you know really
no cuz I the pen it comes to you it
sucks yeah right so but also I think
that's probably more likely to get eaten
like me and Nikki get Thai food whoo how
you gonna [ __ ] eat my taifa can I just
have a pad thai with the fingers you'll
see it - yeah you'll see it I'll know if
you eat some rice because it's a perfect
square every time and then I'll know if
you got into my Tupperware thing cuz the
[ __ ] lids always on so [ __ ] tight
yeah and it's always like filled all the
way to the brim just enough so it
splashes down on the [ __ ] bag you
should think about that when you're
ordering food like that's actually a
really good point
yeah so you're welcome they're saying
that 95% of people tip delivers
regularly and I wouldn't happen I always
give 20% no matter if it's an uber like
a lyft food like I you have I think it's
so important we have you ever told them
give me it back your back the charges on
the card though I feel like if you don't
like exit out of the uber or whatever
like right as soon as like it's over
they like double charge your card you do
does that ever happen to you guys
oh no getting scammed - have you ever
waited hours for your food yep I am
outraged I can take them I typed to the
customer service I'm outraged of your
service yeah took two hours yeah and
then they just give me a refund have you
ever been doing they take the tip away
from them - have you ever been to a
restaurant with all your friends and
then you order food and then nobody
[ __ ] comes for an hour forty five and
they never explain anything to you and
then you leave
no tip at all and your [ __ ] pisses
you leave yep wait what happened someone
stood you up last week Jill you were
there too when know you liked the salad
with no dressing oh the restaurant they
make your friends no yeah we went to
this [ __ ] this I let you guys be
angry because I'm like everyone's pissed
let me be the opposite you know it's
funny to that [ __ ] restaurant is
actually really good and I told my
friends about it [ __ ] is so good
that place is great we were on a [ __ ]
day dude what [ __ ] we got royally [ __ ]
we got so [ __ ] that I couldn't believe
it my salad was had no dressing and it
was it was he it wasn't even like
regular salad leaves it was like clearly
like what they use for some kind of meat
Cup it looked like someone who doesn't
know how to cook yeah yeah you're like
the [ __ ] cooks all went on a strike
and just left like they got in a big
argument they left and then the waiter
had to like cook the food and then not
even tell us that they never apologized
to us or nothing no anyway our waiter
look like she was about to cry though
yes like non-stop I wish she did did I
want to felt no that's true I could have
communicated right alright so since
we're talking about complaints which top
complaints do you guys want to hear from
customers or delivers almost immerse
yeah so their top complaint which is the
percentage consistently irritated is
weak tip or no tip which is 60% that's a
number one I always hear one less you
all [ __ ] up really bad yeah but then
95% of people are tipping yeah so that
means or is it still a week or some [ __ ]
oh the next one is food not ready on
time at the restaurant is 52% also
they're mad at the restaurant because it
looks bad on that yeah which I think
it's still they're bad because again the
communication cuz I've gotten texts from
delivers telling me like hey so sorry
your food still being prepared I'm
waiting for it here at the restaurant
that's great you're gonna get a great
tip cuz you communicated but you don't
communicate and the food's already at
the restaurant is your to your fault you
hear that delivers if you're you can
still catch a movie just Texas chick and
be like yo yeah it's the food's all like
wait take it forever and go watch the
vendors endgame and then when you get
out
this movie and then take honey I got too
much consistently update me every hour
it's gonna interrupt your movie you're
gonna be that [ __ ] with the phone all
lit up and the movie theater true you
know some delivers they're also not
using their brain so one one morning we
ordered a coffee from coffee bean and
then breakfast from somewhere else this
guy he had he got both of the orders
right so instead of like kind of like
kind of strategizing how he's gonna make
his deliveries and all that he got the
coffee bean and I didn't know he got
both orders he got the coffee bean came
to the door and I'm a thank you I got it
and then after like 15 minutes later
oh my breakfast and then I'm like wait
you just thought what you guys deliver
the coffee goes yeah I just realized
that was the hate same house I actually
drove all the way out of the
neighborhood and then back to realize
that it was the same house Wow then he
went to go pick it up for the same
address that sounds like an honest
mistake he was notified of the address
yet that's what I'm saying
they could use their noggin a little bit
more and kind of like see what's
happening the future I get mad at but I
also like the ones that communicate well
especially when they text you like sure
like oh my god they're so into me are
you like that or maybe after they left
like hey you want to go get some lunch
or something sometime yeah there's
actually some super like actors and
stuff do you know because you have to
have a lakeside hustles you're like oh
this is like the beginning of a porno
welcome to my door you could door - here
anytime sorry my pants aren't buttoning
today another complete a towel I hope
it's him again and it's like some other
guy you're like oh [ __ ] yeah the other
complaint from delivers is unclear
instructions from customers in the app
which is 39% and then the customer not
answering the phone which is 37 percent
and then customer messaging deliver with
question slash complaints that's 34
percent of being constantly irritated
customers taking a long time to meet the
deliver to pick up food is 33% and
customers expecting to deliver to walk
up a lot of stairs or take elevators
21% well I don't mind if you're outside
and I gotta go get it okay oh you're
nice oh you you wanted to walk it all
the way up mm-hmm but I know my [ __ ] if
it's inconvenient and I I'm like I'll
meet you halfway or I'll come to you but
if it's but my door front what about the
dudes that pass you the food through the
car window oh that's actually one of
them I had a chick call me and she's
like can you come outside please she's
like I have so many [ __ ] orders I'm
really I'm really running late here and
I went outside and she just like showed
it to me and then she was dressed I
couldn't say no this day she was like
asking for a favor
I [ __ ] hate Chinese dudes that are
delivering okay cuz in they are you know
they don't like they're like speaking
like they're weird English did I don't
understand what the hell they're saying
we're trying to communicate why would
you speak to me they don't speak to say
I'm gonna hear it's a different dialect
Oh as soon as I hear that they need help
I would immediately just jump in oh but
then they talk to me like I'm stupid
when all the directions are really clear
but I guess they can't read it it sound
like [ __ ] so they're confusing what they
read and then they're getting angry at
you yeah that's how I feel when I talk
to stoner pizza guys cuz I don't
understand stoner at all I never smoked
and there are any things I don't
understand what the [ __ ] you're saying
dude like just tell me what's up it says
here 34% of people have had a deliverer
who stayed in the car and passed food
through the window
so 29% have had a deliverer refused to
bring food all the way to the door Wow
17% have had a deliverer dropped food
outside and leave
what what's wrong with like that it's
like a home delivery like drive-through
sort of thing I actually don't
I agree but Gio's like you know I don't
think so if they drop it off like at
your door like you know in their car
whatever it's like a [ __ ]
drive-through at your house people
should install drive-through windows at
homes so when the door - people come or
whatever they could just pull up bail
please get rich Oh God that's Nijo a
billionaire yep wait I came up with the
idea yeah no no it's just cuz he has me
and he would actually and
we didn't do it right because you're
like that's tacky as [ __ ] no I would buy
be cool do it you would you'd make it
look what you think yeah you'd fall
through the everything
I can't yeah I would hide it with like
maybe like a tropical look yeah you
should have like lights in it to like
different alert like lights Joe would
get that [ __ ] aquarium background
stuff it just tack it all over the walls
I need camouflage gear oh my gosh it's
all neon and bright no vodka and you
just look like you're in an aquarium
what's your problem it's not it's not a
catch-all that's amazing yeah so they're
saying that delivers which we mentioned
earlier 28 percent said yes they have
taken food from an order and then they
54% of them said that they have been
tempted by the smell of food yeah they
deliver they been tempted but did they
eat the forbidden fruit and then for
customers they're saying would you like
restaurants to use tamper-evident labels
to address 85% of people said yes yeah
don't they like cover the bag now put a
sticker on and all that yeah you guys
like the ones that come with the hungry
girlfriend you know sometimes that the
guys driving and you could tell they
they probably been on like some uber
eats date oh I know you didn't eat it
but you're hungry ask girl for by eights
on my fries
that's so funny you don't like that word
too sometimes I look at the photo of the
deliver and then a different person
comes up and gave away food oh yeah
that's so weird
like their moms in the car it's hot soup
and I burn myself
your mom care about you Oh child labor
is awesome maybe then that's a tactic to
get you to tip tomorrow oh yeah kids are
honest too kids like this sucks kind of
gross and then you're like oh you had my
[ __ ] suit
they're like sick and stuff and then
like
it
[Music]
[Music]